I'll come to this video I'm playing the
missing link
let's check this no it's got a ton of
text but not the name and I am from the
Netherlands yeah yeah I recently lost
very very awfully with anything with the
Knight f6 let's play something more
solid TM 97 them yeah not quite sure
what the name is I think that it's
usually connected with the cap off and
hence Mislav probably Smith's off okay
so this is some very simple approach for
why it's just exchanged on f6 and
develop pieces however this shouldn't
shouldn't be very dangerous from black
yeah I know my pieces developed came
this night might be an annoyance let's
exchange it yeah I don't really see em
how white is going to make any sort of
substantial progress and the same type
of position take it this leads to two
further exchanges it wasn't strictly
necessary to play c5 I could yeah maybe
I should have played in a bit more
complicated manner
we'd be six or something I mean this is
completely alright the Sun pollution but
it's it's not very very exciting to play
between f6 to g6
hmm yeah you might might have played
with Ruby salmon hmm the play look d8
Bishop g5
and this looks a bit shaky maybe I need
to do that very quick reply
so to stroke the agent yeah it's this is
why I mostly play this Bronstein Larsen
if I played the comic-con in in in those
blitz games as you sometimes lose
horribly but it tends to tends to be a
bit more interesting yeah this isn't
very thrilling okay
yeah the position is some just just very
equal he can try to do something with
them with this queenside three against
two try to push the pawns it's nothing
that should be a very challenging
hmm
here should be six in my place he form
but I have bishop de Flore came some
another problem a danger it would have
been dangerous if he would managed I've
managed to place c5 and sort of isolate
on him in my bishop here on my seventh
okay so what and I badly need to to
improve my back rank and maybe I can
play each form harassing the bishop and
getting some counter play again self
tuned yeah I don't think really am I
have any any problems here unless I just
blundered possible he's attacking this
at the ticking age five hmm that's bad
so I didn't lose a pawn which is good
but I'm down almost 1 minutes on the
clock
it's probably the the biggest is the
biggest issue here position I don't mind
so much
nepeta king him or carry that's a bit
passive probably played this rather well
it got is some queen activated
I didn't really consider that move this
could be a problem
Makena cannot help now I just forgot
about that I'm losing him fear
is it a five now I want to know
didn't think so no if I was not the
problem
he takes king of 76 I'm just in time to
at least not do not that he cannot
promote it wait
King u6 can you five hmm now I'm winning
this pawn do that I should have played
c6 earlier I think 94 of course I need
to play ephors for stupid quantity for
him it's not it's not a big problem but
would have been much easier time morning
check check yeah considering the little
time I have I play played very safe just
yet
get rid of from the last pawn so then I
at least don't lose on time completely
game Gerard is actually winning of
course yeah give me increment No
yeah yeah it's probably err should have
been been the draw all the way around
here
or maybe I can make him play b5 and he
did play b5 so let's let's check this he
somehow lost lots of time so what was
the issue here he needs to play b6 and
tending c6 yeah this is very strong over
I'm just losing yeah Quinn d4 was losing
blunder than I'm slightly under pressure
that that's clear but yeah I played I
played it in precisely reform I
shouldn't get into a lost position after
Bishop deform on perfectly alright
but it's a matter of precision probably
h5 wasn't great it looks good to test
this idea and give some comfort to the
king Florrie I should have played this
one also blocking oh no this is a bit
weird no blocking this diagonal yeah I
was very worried about the back rank but
the computer says basically it's not not
a problem
yeah it's very very much a matter of
precise calculation and with Queen d4
should have lost all right thanks for
watching